yoro excuses aujourd'hui pour jouer à
deux petits jeux on commence tout de
suite avec week-end drive c'est un jeu
dans lequel il ya trois mini jeux on va
commencer avec météorite drive on va
s'amuser c'est une pluie de météorites
va à l'abri ok c'est pas c'est parti on
y va attendez quoi ce bullshit et quoi
c'est juste ça voilà donc les météorites
sont hyper réaliste effectivement soirée
près sud en 2012
la fin du monde mais c'était pas le cas
1 on est bel et bien d'un week-end drive
oh là là regardez moi il traverse les
bâtiments ils essaient de s'en sortir
c'est compliqué il prend un autre
itinéraire avec son gps tomtom là il ya
des trous à la météorite l'a frappé il
se relève aisément sa place au regard du
terme et c'est qu'un nom et c'est le
vide c'est à temps il ya une pluie d'été
aux rites et ensuite on est sur une
passerelle de crédit sol quand j'étais
sur mes potes
allez-y les gars je vous tire le temps
ça vous fait accélérer vis à vis arriver
au chili où je suis dans une pluie de
météorites je vais m'en sortir à votre
windows
un jeu qui crache la punit torride ou
hockey deuxième mini genazzi la hight
nazis la chope des roquettes et attire
sur naji là pour le défoncer plats aux
toitures ou qu'unique faut s'offrir
n'est pas une voiture un truc à une
voiture [ __ ] adil a été brillant comme
montrent eux on se tire ça je suppose
indiqué andrew ya des roquettes c'est ça
ou la personne qui nous aident quoi
bouder les annonces de 22 mètres sans
déconner qui qui nous attaque
elle décide de déployer deux soldats
vont pas y avait une roquette vers là je
la vois pas what what attendant la
soldate bouge pas l'entrée mais [ __ ]
le qu'on cherchait de roquettes
hop là allez tire mon pote à mourir mon
pote m'a bourré avec oi tous mourir et
la ouate
j'ai bien être champion fait vos preuves
laissez moi sortir je m'en vais dans
cette petite rue dans le vieux bruit
quoi on dira version obtenu l' la
passion de courir avec aucune musique en
arrière plan c'est totalement vide
seulement des petits bruits de pas et
les revend où allez vous voilà ma
démarche
[Musique]
retour à la réalité au cannet à l'entrée
comme disait orelsan voilà en deux
cultures deux ans mon dieu là il ya des
requêtes je le sens là c'est la deuxième
base de la vie la [ __ ] la somme et
diouf faut que certains mots qu'il
arrive faut que certains voient qu'il
arrive fonctionne un vrai gars là il me
sens faire mais [ __ ] c'est mal foutu
59e sorti là-bas la bombe là en dessous
on glisse non non c'est la bataille
naples est la seule à bord
le lavage autres feuilles d'or de mon
gars non il m'a gober je te fais un à
dix doigts biatch voilà c'est très court
jeu suivant showa wii / dad simulateur
2015 new style so why we see your daddy
ce que vous touchez votre père moi des
fois ça m'arrive en ce jeu qui
trouveront ça c'est un tout petit jeu
toku et vous m'avez causé en masse parce
qu'il est là l'air très addictif et très
amusant alors ya plusieurs modes de jeu
alors comme en se parant du roda trop
faire quoi pour faire quoi
ajoie et voilà c'est parti johaneck je
dois en jour n'ont pas pas sous la
douche je voyais le bon papa non mais
attends je tourne beaucoup comme une
grosse merde que papa [ __ ] voit même
les saisies quoi ce n'est pas censuré
c'est exceptionnel et laulala
l'enchaînement
oh
[Musique]
oh non le petit rouquine et la voilà je
dois trouver le père qui correspond à
cette fois l'enfant change à chaque fois
par exemple assez lui hop là l'enfant a
changé ses fils de qui lui ces fissures
ou oui ça c'est en or langage de son
père papa je te vois pas où est en fait
on a un temps fait pas pour trouver le
bon papa y avait une et ça ça en est où
sauf double point aller au maire le mec
qui gâche tout une seconde quoi en amont
j'en ai lancé à mais d'une puissance
regarder cette incroyable slalom
véritablement entre les pères qui ne
sont pas les nôtres à regarder le talent
le temps où j'ai pas fait exprès pour la
marche au lavage c'est justement
pourquoi je garde ça j'adore pour des
couchettes mon père aiguille ça on a pu
taper dans mon gars doux à la stella fin
on voit à l'entraînement l'effet de
jouer plusieurs minutes déjà
ça procure fermant une certaines
stations locales ce traître azor il est
cool que je peux le temps de dire oh ils
sont tombés ou ayant des choses
voilà à quoi sert alors à toi [ __ ] à
jean tentera comme le plus grand des
connards ça abusé je parle même plus je
veux juste faire le meilleur score
possible et imaginable corps et et si
vous avez vous reprenez a prédit jacques
votre père vous aussi vous allez voir
que vous avez traire comme de [ __ ] on
contribue à un certain stade ya des
flaques parterre quoi pourtant dû en
erreur il ya il fait glisser sur un
autre papa quoi c'est un crime c'est
puni par la loi savent pas par où tu
avais cette musique me met en transe un
truc de fou yard avait en totale et
trans c'est un peu comme les totally
spies mais version trop soir on s'amuse
tellement regardé plus tard et est
maintenant glissé [ __ ] vous chez vous
voulez vraiment pas johan temps passé
sous la douche
mais ces montres sacs ou droite
alan doss juste abusé quoi aller tôt
elle offre moi je me tire de ses douches
bordel ya quoi que votre mode d'atv
jeunes c'est quoi ça je peux bouger je
peux changer ma couleur et il faut que
j'attrape le bon papa problème pour luc
leroux le rôle roues oh là là à temps
c'est vachement compliqué avec sont les
connaît c'est carrément on en voit car
on ne peint sur leur pénis quoi on les
fistons cas ça n'a aucun sens ce qui se
passe touche les fesses pourquoi ne faut
surtout pas jouer à ce jeu quand vos
parents sont chez vous un vraiment il
risquerait d'y avoir co fut c'est ou
bien la petit blanc c'est pour moi
n'empêche c'est l'europe ce qu'il aurait
fait un truc con alors qu'en vrai j'ai
eu carrément bien quoi olala c'est
commence à l'e3 c'est parce que tu crois
ma mort jabra travers d'un jeu ou
putatifs touché c'est ton père quoi
humane bordel fonctionne cette chaîne
youtube ça doit te remplir jay des vies
en bas à droite chaque fois que je rate
ou que je prends nommé papa ça me retire
une demie non mais arrête mais qui abuse
pas non plus à 65 papa consécutif eh ben
j'ai bien là mais ce mode là moi à
mettre des doigts comme ça dans les
vannes pour attraper mais nos papas
tandis que les jours cela devrait quand
même à la nature en fait tu peux style
et les papas ya pas besoin de bouger
pourquoi bouger quand on peut tous
attrapé instant sur place je sais avec
mon gars donc là que l'on mon métier se
résume à attraper les papas
correspondant par le zizi voilà répond
me demande ce que je fais dans la vie
jeudi
j'attrape des papas correspondant par
leur visite c'est vraiment un métier un
palpitant que tout le monde apprécie et
effectivement et espen je fais la garde
à vue à cause de cette question ça finit
mal à chaque fois je sais pas pourquoi
les gens comprennent pas voilà j'en
tiens pas de cette vidéo ce père comme
ça vous a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
à toucher évoque maintenant a aimé la
vidéo je veux pas être responsable si
vous touchez 10 de votre papa non mais
comprenez l'eau arrive encore faire de
la garde à vue déjà que j'en fais tout
le temps
cette vidéo fortement bien que tu ne
puisses
[Musique]